so charlie morton sporting the home reds
for the braves on a beautiful friday
night charlie is pitching for the third
time against the phillies he's two and
one with a 508 and you mentioned jeff
the big inning that is kind of in a
nutshell why the big innings happened
against him
climbing into the left-hand batter's box
bryce harper six homers 10 rbis 3-1
pitch missed the inside corner and
there's ball four
strikeout pass ball followed by the walk
now jt romuto climbing in
henry almuto shoots one into left field
to base it here comes hoskins around
third ozuna will hustle it back in and
they hold the base runner the phillies
have the bases loaded for alec balm
and baum loops it into right field to
base it one run is in harper's being
held it's an rbi single and the phillies
jump out to a one-nothing lead gene con
just activated today off the injured
list on there with the right quad strain
since the 21st he was a big part of the
offense before he went down won one
pitch swung on ground ball the other way
it's past freeman it goes down the line
one run will score two runs are home and
gene segura back in the lineup with a
two-run single and the phillies take a
three-nothing lead here in the first
here comes odubal herrera who finally
started to sting the baseball a little
bit here the last few days
one one is lined out to right center
field and pasha is not gonna get it it's
out of the ballpark oh double herrera
three run home run that ball just kept
on sailing and the phillies are on top
six nothing first home run of the year
for herrera and the phillies are busting
it open early and if you had wagered
that the braves would give up six runs
in the first inning to the phillies with
a packed house and charlie morton on the
mound you might want to go play the
powerball charlie morton faces 10
hitters he gets two outs
zach eflin's been staked to the six run
lead this is a seventh start one to one
a 3.49
era but you still have to make a quality
pitch on this young man
and a strike three calls
it is an odd first hitting strike zone
that benefited the phillies in the top
of the first and according to that
our box it benefits them here oh for 16
in may one for his last 21. one two
pitch
swing and a miss struck him out
so back-to-back strikeouts to get things
started do you like to see that
brings dansby swanson up to the plate
dansby shoots one toward right center
field that ball is carrying that ball is
in the bullpen
and when dansby does that jeff that
makes him a very very dangerous hitter
and it's six to one
back toward the middle caught by zach
effort
long arm the law right there how excited
he was
well two on
and here's odubal herrera who homered
his first time up here's the stretch and
the pitch swung on and
hitting the air down the left field line
going in coming in on his ozuna he won't
have a play or he can't get to it i
should say and it drops in for a hit
everybody moves up 90 feet and here
comes andrew mccutchen but this is a big
moment i think for the phillies after
getting
six in the first i mean you gotta be
able to add on he kicks and fires in the
pitch swung on ground ball hit towards
short charging in swanson flips to
second there's one on to first
not in time
and a run is home as dd gregorius will
score and the phillies now lead it seven
to one
here's ozzy albee's
to lead off philly's seven in the braves
one here's the one two pitch
swing at a miss high fastball elevating
on albie's and he strikes out here's
austin riley who popped out his first
time up
0-2
swing and a miss
struck him out back-to-back strikeouts
for effluent that's now five in the game
so now contreras who grounded out his
first time up
and it's a foul tip hung onto by jt
and contreras almost standing there
wondering what just happened to me
well he is struck out and effluent
strikes out the side braves go in order
frames have 15 outs left down six runs
be nice to make eflin work a little bit
he's been a nice groove he just struck
out the side he has set down eight
consecutive braves hitters
snapped a long
streak harper can't get it the ball's
behind him he can't find it
dansby's on his way to second that's
where he'll stand to lead off the inning
so two out runner at second back to the
top we go and ronald acuna who was
called out on strikes in the first
broke his bat and flied out in the third
big lead for swanson at second and a
shot in a shallow right another chance
for harper won't get this one that's
down for a hit give a cuny an rbi and
the braves are down 7-2
man freddie you talk about igniting this
crowd great opportunity he's won for his
last 22 at the plate runner goes san
freddie shoots one into the shift and
right at segura who makes the peg and
the braves settle for one in the fifth
inning a good job by zach eflin to limit
the damage there in the fifth so pop up
a walk a strikeout and another walk down
the scoring position goes rhys hoskins
alec baum with one of those hits that
came in the first drove in the first run
of the game
that one should sharply throw the hole
in the right side rounding third heading
for home as hoskins he'll score going to
third is real muto rbi single for baum
is second ribby of the night and the
phil's leading eight to two
[Music]
zac effluent goes to work as we begin
the bottom of the six
mizuno loops one in the center of base
hit
lead off single
here at the bottom of the six that's his
second hit
broken background ball cut off by bone
goes to second for one back to first and
it's in time
five four three double play i don't ball
played that with a lot of confidence
here's the pitch
and it's down and in gets away from
contreras
and segura will take third base
the pitch swung on and ripped into left
there's a base hit
and trotting home with the ninth run of
the night for the phillies is jean
segura on the rbi single
by andrew mccutchen
it's nine to two phillies
we're going to the bottom of the seventh
and
zac effluent will get back to work here
for the phillies like he was throwing
hard
a call strike three on the outside
corner eight strikeouts for effluent
joe's coming out
that's it
wow pitching change in atlanta
99 pitches six and two thirds innings
with eight strikeouts and a 9-2 lead
bryce harper with a double lead-off
double here in the a there's j.t romuto
a high fly ball to left center field
it's deep going back on it is pasha he
jumps it's gone
a two-run home run for real muto his
fourth of the year closer to 100 for his
career
and the phillies leading 11-2
ground ball to second
albie's
is able to get
maitan who came on the run for gene
segora as a double herrera with a four
rbi night
scoring is dede gregorius and it's now
12 to two phillies
growl ball towards shortstop mate todd
is up with it fires across the diamond
in time and the ball game is over the
phillies have won five straight they win
it tonight 12-2